hello youtube and welcome to part 13 of
let's play amnesia the Dark Descent
thank you so much for joining us and I
am on my way to a mysterious place the
chancel not sure what a chancel is that
that word never heard of it
all right up more stable lots of stairs
love my stairs at least Daniel's getting
his exercise could use a little whoa
who's there who's there not afraid of
you dare hard there blue fire is that
you who's there
nobody a whole lot of nobody are you do
you shut up
show your face that's right door aw he
won't budge okay I believe that you up
chase you down ah no not just further
it's like a theist descending into the
underworld
who's worthless you hiding something
what do you mean never mind your
intuition is remarkable yeah I'm sure
one blue ink oh god he's patrolling oh
I'll go faster
Oh go faster not right now
oh [ __ ] no oh god oh god oh god oh god
Oh what I still that ah oh it's bad dumb
all those dumb where am i where am I
going
I don't know much oh no oh God oh no no
no I go I go I go I go missing take a
barrel in the face you bastard
jump ah okay okay I'm okay
okay run Oh run Oh run ah the music Oh
blue fire save me ah ah stop music now
cazador
how did you do oh yeah who's yours over
oh no now your blood red army hey buff
okay oh okay
yeah yeah how you doing all dog good
down oh oh guy
okay yeah oh nothing nothing nothing
whatsoever I still there oh I'm getting
down here I'm getting at here oh go away
go away go away go away
ah okay all right okay huh
okay huh okay
all right okay I don't like the chancel
I don't like it I don't like it at all
that's not that's not something I I want
to do huh okay all right uh-huh okay
Daniel stop being so scared unless you
do this
anybody there okay right
you're finally gone yeah gone
he's gone okay finally go I wind you're
hardly a comparison and scared etude
miss to the monster not that he was
scary at all cuz I don't get scared
ha-ah
alright start over Agrippa tried
everything huh or brin resort of a power
centuries of thing but ah yeah yeah
whatever
the goes Alexander rambling like an
idiot like he usually does this is
what's all this then you sit right in
right there yep
that's what I meant good job oh this
looks like a trap oh it's definitely a
trap what's this oil that's what this is
there's nothing
a big pile and nothing just like my
hopes and dreams ha ha that right
okay I think pretty sure that in this
room there was nothing because the door
couldn't budge but I was kind of in a
hurry
in and out of it so maybe there was
something I missed
who knows shut up Daniel you murdering
psycho
this is bucket ATAR on the fault of
oldest ah 1839 banishment ritual is
taking longer than expected and we have
to do what is needed or do you spend my
time helping out the prisoner helping
out being around these degenerates makes
me ill oh really
none of them even tries to face their
punishment with any kind of dignity
ah they taught me with their lies of
universe and their cowardly pleas of
mercy oh yeah how dare they make a man
fall so far from the grace of a
civilized exist yeah I know they are all
wicked men and I remind myself of it
constantly still I am thankful for God
sending these monsters our way as they
will serve as the instruments of my
salvation yeah okay I try to study the
different tools in the torture chamber
Oh know how to use them I knew it well I
know it's messy and the effect suffered
from my inexperience Daniel is a sick
psychopath formed I knew it I shall be
ready yeah
alright maybe I should just throw him
into the way of one of the monsters I
think you guys deserve to die
Marge fudge Halen sin scenery
I got my bucket ATAR now what do I do
with it let's see what are you come here
come here
Apple cannabis cannabis no time for that
come more exploring to do I don't need a
lantern when I get all this blue fire
which is totally natural and I'm sure
would actually last forever which I
assume it has been what the hell is that
who's there oh that's yeah wow that's
that's normal
perfectly reasonable technology for this
time period uh-huh yeah I believe it
oh yeah maybe perfect for an award but
maybe anything you know whole bunch no
like everywhere else just a bunch of
nothing
is this guilt I'm missing Dan no playing
yourself you stop it's not I think you
did you sent me that letter asking for
nila oh yes he's how to repay me yeah
your help was murdering people how dad
all right
I don't think there's anything else to
be found here Oh
puh I need to figure out how to get
those doors open
seriously what's with the rose petals is
if someone just following me around just
dropping rose petals everywhere I mean
that's very lovely and all that kind of
doesn't fit the theme knave
all right out of my way and ah come on
these cells are mental prisoners who are
under treatment treatment the people you
send for will end up here okay remember
that the confinement itself works as a
preamble to the torture our line you
should pace yourself don't take anyone
before they are ready the yellow star
sounds from the torture chambers are
shuttled in through those pipes in the
ceiling manage your victims well and let
one prisoner's pain instill terror in
his cellmate that's fantastic
Boop hello ah ah okay I hate the buzzing
because what what if you really go down
to Alex laughs would you consider taking
me this you know I know itself
ridiculous
I mean look but if you find anything
concerning a man named Johan I don't
care if you please bring it to know I
want I believe he was working on a way
to help them know I was for some sort of
potion yeah right talking to three
friends of us come on I don't believe
you you're liar you're dirty dirty liar
build my tower into this thing be on my
way cuz I don't care about so many of my
life Saunders things are breaking down
yeah no kidding Oh God maybe's possible
gel machine watching Oh
you'll find the bigger picture
yup
lemmya Oh aha is that it
don't care shut up go away get out right
maybe that fixed the levers in the
beginning oh two levers two doors do all
right that makes sense I'll stop with
the moaning nobody cares
Oh what the hell wait man wait ah wait
wait where's doors is this this one
oh yeah go bam genius
oh man oh so smart smartness losing out
my eyeballs cuz that word it drains from
your brain gets too full of smartness
has to drain
we obviously can't drain out your ears
cause I'd be logical yeah
shut up too far no I haven't you know
you don't I can't let your receding yeah
right I'm sorry my friend shut up no one
likes you
from what I've heard you're almost as
big an a-hole as Daniel here is No shut
up
you got two doors open good I'm doing
whatever what's all this then
hello put their water monster fun times
transept not sure what that is but it
sounds dirty
ro pentagram herb 1 2 3
septa Graham sorry sorry I know my I
know my signals Oh an octa Graham
how much more am i some first wit stuff
this one prepare her right
that doesn't seem good
Donita
ah oh I thought that oh I thought that
was the totally freaky oh I get it I get
it I get it I get it I get it
do you guys get it I get it I get it oh
yeah see nope huh
torture reaction thankfully right pause
it if you wonder with them pause it if
you want to read this three two one
but string I came all the way up here
for some string yes oh hello
black eagle Napoleon Napoleon oil see
that pain is so creepy
okay I actually have to pause this here
but don't worry I'm gonna keep going and
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you in part 13 good bye